welcome back to cbs this morning the
start of the school year is just
weeks away and millions of parents are
worried about
what's next for their children me
included many are juggling work
and family life during this pandemic in
our series the new normal we look at how
the coronavirus is changing
everyday lives meg oliver shows us how
many families are struggling to cope
there were times where i you know had to
pull myself out of bed
and it was just not finding motivation
throughout the day
for jennifer valenzuela the carefree
days of a california summer have been
anything but
when the swiss goes down in march that
wasn't distance learning
that was emergency learning the 31 year
old mom of two had three jobs and was
going back to school when covet 19
hit the u.s having to manage you know
doing
mom duties and also being a teacher for
them and
trying to study myself you know it was
really difficult it was a big change for
all of us
valenzuela and her kids have asthma she
says that means traditional schooling is
not an option for now
nor is staying in the workforce do you
feel like you have to choose over the
safety of your children
versus making a living and going back
to work i do honestly i really do that's
something that i've been struggling with
because i do have three jobs so you know
i can't realistically do all three
and you know take care of my children
the emotional strain on parents
stretches across the country
how stressed are you i'm a morning
person now i don't even want to get up
in the morning
alicia alvarez lives in dallas with her
husband and three children
her oldest has adhd add and is bipolar
in april she quit her job as a bus
monitor for special needs students to
stay home
full time it's so hard being a parent
right now
because these kids don't understand you
can't go outside and play with your
friends
that isolation is really taking a toll
isn't it
my 14 year old has been home since march
13th
when spring break started and he stays
in his room and i
can't stand that i have to force him
to go to come to come outside there you
go keep pushing
in west orange new jersey the wine shank
family is juggling a role reversal
it's been a disaster it
took everything we knew and threw it up
in the air and brought it back down
mom lauren an essential worker at a
local hospital goes into work five days
a week
leaving dad matthew who works at a new
york city bank home to juggle
remote working and remote learning with
two kids
matt went from not knowing the kids
schedules
not knowing what you know activities
had to be done not knowing really much
about their schoolwork not because he's
not involved but just because he
physically
wasn't there to really taking over
everything it is challenging but
you need to also keep in mind you can
only
focus on what you can control it's a
matter of accepting the day-to-day
change and that we cannot plan out for
the future
catherine perlman an associate professor
of social work at brandman university
has been coaching parents through this
summer of uncertainty
how do parents survive this we were in
survival mode for
a good three to four months and you know
we can do anything for three to four
months
but now we're moving into the fall and
people have lost the thrill
of the survival back in california
jennifer valenzuela says
she's surviving an optimism it was a
different outlook now for the fall i'm
hopeful that you know there has been
more planning more training i'm hoping
for the best
perlman is encouraging parents to think
weeks ahead instead of months ahead to
manage the stress
she also says it's important for parents
to come together right now
helping others even in the smallest ways
can help you too
especially if you're struggling with
anxiety gail
boy meg i feel for all those mothers
jennifer laura and alisha i thought
lauren said it best that covet just took
everything we knew
threw it up in the air let it let it
fall and it's like you all figure it out
it's tough
it's very very tough really tough
you've got kids at home too so you
understand we've seen you homeschooling
too
it's a lot to do
thank you very much meg oliver